This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人出品。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，而在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你只要有这个能力就非得这么做，听听并吸取
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用艰难的方式在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO.%，可在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。去听《闺蜜》播客。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看当年》（Look Back at it）播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊 80 年代。
84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as
84 年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，非常高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，因为
we of course break down the very important psychology of our 20s. I'm going to cut straight to the chase. Today, we're going to be talking about political anxiety and political uncertainty. Something that I think we could all do with some more information about at the moment and maybe some comfort as well, given the recent election. I just want to say, straight off the bat from the top, this is not a space for any hate or negativity. And if you are listening to this episode with that intention or you're looking to start an argument, you're looking to make a point, I would kindly ask that you move on to one of our many other episodes, just with respect for those of us who are feeling differently to you.
我们当然要剖析我们二十岁时非常重要的心理学。我就开门见山了。今天，我们要聊聊政治焦虑和政治不确定性。鉴于最近的选举，我认为这正是我们目前都需要了解更多信息，或许也需要一些慰藉的话题。我只想从一开始就声明，这个空间不容任何仇恨或消极情绪。如果你带着这种意图收听本期节目，或者你想挑起争端、急于表达观点，我恳请你移步去听我们的其他众多节目，这也是为了尊重我们当中那些感受与你不同的人。
You know, I'm recording this the day after the US election and I know that tensions are high. So if you were happy with the results of the election, then you probably don't need this episode. But there are people who do. and I hope that you can respect that for this moment. I just want to put that out there because my focus with this podcast has always been on making people feel like they have a space to just feel their feelings, whatever they may be. As ugly, as horrible, as negative, as dark as they are, I just simply want you to know that you are not alone and just to find ways for you to find peace within the turmoil, of our 20s and beyond. And I think a lot of us need that right now. There is something very specific on a lot of our minds that is increasing that turmoil. You know, there is a lot of angst, there is a lot of
你知道，我是美国大选结束的第二天录制这期节目的，我知道此时情绪非常紧绷。所以，如果你对选举结果感到满意，那你可能不需要这期节目。但确实有人需要。我希望你能暂时尊重这一点。我只想先把话挑明，因为我做这个播客的初衷一直是让人们觉得他们有一个空间，可以去纯粹地感受自己的情绪，无论它们是什么样。不管它们多么丑陋、多么可怕、多么消极、多么阴暗，我只是想让你知道，你并不孤单，并帮你找到在二十岁及以后的动荡岁月中寻找内心平静的方法。我想我们现在很多人都需要这个。在我们许多人的脑海中，有一些非常具体的事情正在加剧这种动荡。你知道，有很多焦虑，有很多
stress, anxiety to do with what the future holds after the outcome of this election, but also just in general when it comes to increasing polarization and division almost everywhere we look. I know a lot of us are concerned about our freedoms, our safety, our rights, what the future holds for us in many domains, you know, the environment, foreign policy, the economy and just genuine empathy and kindness in the world. We are seeing so much suffering and injustice. And it is not a pleasant feeling to be sitting in, especially since that feeling in particular jeopardizes some of our very core needs as humans. We need to feel secure. We need to feel a sense of stability and certainty. Our human brains don't like uncertainty because
压力，对于这次大选结果之后的未来会怎样感到焦虑，而且普遍来说，当我们看到几乎无论看向哪里都在日益加剧的极化和分裂时，也是如此。我知道我们很多人都在关心我们的自由、我们的安全、我们的权利、我们在许多领域的未来会走向何方，你知道的，环境、外交政策、经济，以及世界真正的同理心和善良。我们看到了如此多的苦难和不公。置身其中绝对不是一种愉悦的感受，尤其是这种特定的感受正危及我们作为人类的一些最核心需求。我们需要感到安全。我们需要一种稳定感和确定感。我们的人类大脑不喜欢不确定性，因为
it triggers our survival instincts, which have very much evolved to help us avoid danger. You may think that these very ancient systems don't really apply when it comes to political outcomes or elections or anything of the sort, but it very much does. If you don't know what is going to happen, and everything in your mind and your body is telling you that, that they're not, you, that they're not, the outcome won't be good and it's going to be harmful to those that you love. This is something that you are going to be hypervigilant towards. This is something that will trigger stress. And the outcome of an election, current political circumstances, social circumstances,
它会触发我们的生存本能，而这种本能很大程度上是为了帮助我们避开危险而进化的。你可能会觉得这些古老的系统在政治结果、选举或任何类似的事情面前并不真的适用，但事实并非如此。如果你不知道接下来会发生什么，而你脑海和身体里的每一个信号都在告诉你，事情不会好转，结果不会是好的，并且会对你所爱的人造成伤害。这是你会高度警惕的事情。这是会引发压力的事情。选举的结果，当前的政治环境、社会环境，
those are all very valid triggers. Our fight or flight response is triggered by major societal, political, environmental change, especially when the stakes are high. And I think with recent events, often our fears can feel very unreal and abstract. And this isn't some abstract fear. This isn't some abstract, scary thought. The fear for many of us, it did come true. This could have consequences for us. And this definitely creates an even deeper emotional investment and acknowledgement of what's happened in the past and also fear around what could potentially and might actually happen in the future, there is a significant increase in fear that comes from that. And whilst we could typically call that catastrophizing,
这些都是非常切实的诱因。当面临重大的社会、政治、环境变革时，我们的战斗或逃跑反应就会被触发，尤其是当利害攸关的时候。而且我认为随着最近发生的事件，通常我们的恐惧会显得非常不切实际和抽象。但这并不是什么抽象的恐惧。这不是某种抽象的、可怕的想法。对于我们许多人来说，对未来的恐惧真的成为了现实。这可能会给我们带来后果，这绝对会产生更深的感情投入，让我们对过去发生的事情产生认可，同时也对未来可能甚至确实会发生的事情感到恐惧，由此产生的恐惧感显著增加。虽然我们通常可以把这称作灾难化思维，
you know, maybe there is a tendency to think, you know, no, like this is just catastrophic thinking. It's not going to be that bad. I think some of our fears don't feel unrealistic. And that is a really scary thought, that there is something that might be likely to occur as a result of this election, as a result of the political climate that we really don't want to face. And all of that is based in very human, very animal, very evolutionary anxiety that is meant to keep you safe in these moments. And that is meant to spur you on to do something. It's just that right now, it doesn't feel like you can. So I just want to tell you, what you are feeling is, completely understandable. Distress is a very valid emotional response when it feels like the world
你知道，也许有一种倾向会认为，不，这只是灾难化的想法。没那么糟糕。我认为我们的一些恐惧并非不切实际。这是一个非常可怕的想法，也就是说，由于这次选举的结果，由于我们真的不想面对的政治气候，确实有些事情很有可能会发生。这一切都植根于非常人性化、非常动物性、非常进化的焦虑之中，这种焦虑旨在这些时刻保护你的安全。它本意是激励你采取行动。只是现在，你感觉自己无能为力。所以我只想告诉你，你的感受是完全可以理解的。当世界感觉像在
is collapsing and it feels like that right now. I've received messages from so many of you saying that you feel so alone. It feels like society is going backwards, that this is not the kind of world that you want to live in. How can you plan for a future? What can you expect from your future? And I very much understand right now how very, very hard it is to put into words all the scenarios that our brains are cooking up. There's also a real sense of political fatigue. You know, for all the progress that we've made for how much hope we had, for how deeply we believe in what is right. Surely there is some way to fix this, but we're just too exhausted to even think of it right now. There is just too many emotions running amok. There is just too much stress almost paralyzing us. But we can't live in
分崩离析时，痛苦是非常合理的心理反应，而现在感觉就是这样。我收到了你们中许多人的信息，说你们感到如此孤独。感觉社会在倒退，这不是你们想要生活的世界。怎么能为未来做规划？你能对未来有什么期待？我非常理解，现在要把大脑中酝酿的所有情境用言语表达出来，是多么、多么困难。这里也确实存在一种政治疲劳感。你知道的，尽管我们取得了所有进步，怀揣着那么多希望，对什么是正确的有着如此坚定的信仰。肯定有什么办法能解决这个问题，但我们太累了，甚至现在都无法去想它。情绪实在过于失控。压力实在太大，几乎让我们陷入瘫痪。但我们不能永远活在
that distress and this anxiety forever as much as it might feel like we're doing something about the problem, we're not. And that is the space that I want to move us into, the space where we can think more clearly about what we can do next. We can think more clearly about how we can look after ourselves, how we can approach this with a stoic mindset, with any mindset that helps us actually live, I guess. Essentially, there may not be a way to fix what has happened, but there is a better way to cope and there is a way to return to at least a sense of internal safety, even as wild things are happening outside, even as things in the future seem to threaten us. So from here on out, we are not going to talk about any specifics to do with the election, no specifics to do with
那种痛苦和焦虑中，不管它感觉起来多么像是我们在为解决问题做些什么，其实并没有。而这正是我希望带大家进入的那个空间，一个我们可以更清晰地思考下一步该做什么的空间。我们可以更清晰地思考如何照顾好自己，如何以斯多葛式的思维方式来面对这一切，以任何能真正让我们活下去的思维方式来面对。本质上，也许没有办法修复已经发生的事情，但有一种更好的应对方式，有一种方法能够让我们至少恢复一种内在的安全感，即便外界正发生着疯狂的事情，即便未来的事情似乎在威胁着我们。所以从现在开始，我们将不再谈论任何与选举有关的具体细节，不再谈论任何与
politics. Our focus is just on how to take care of yourself and those that you love and how to take care of your mind. That is our one job here from here on out. And I really just want to give you the space to have maybe a mental break from reading the news, from absorbing that kind of content and that kind of information. And instead give you some of the best psychology-based tips for managing the elevated political anxiety and stress that many of us have at the time. the moment. So without further ado, let's get into this. Hopefully, this is helpful. Hopefully, you better understand the political anxiety you might be experiencing right now. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
政治相关的具体细节。我们的重点只在于如何照顾好你自己和你爱的人，以及如何照顾好你的心灵。这就是我们从今以后唯一的任务。我真的只是想给你这样一个空间，让你能从阅读新闻、吸收这类内容和信息中进行一次精神上的暂离。转而为你提供一些基于心理学的最佳建议，来管理我们许多人在当前这个时刻所感受到的高涨的政治和心理压力。闲话少说，让我们切入正题吧。希望这能对大家有所帮助。希望你能更好地理解自己此刻可能正在经历的政治焦虑。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, research, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO.%，可在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈 80 年代瘾品的节目。澄清一下，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时都可以聊瘾品，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode
讨论瘾品的节目了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在台面上了，所以…… 谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeart Radio
where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah, for me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart
应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难抉择》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们在追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们盯着计分板生活，人生变成了赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要，
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth
还是你成为好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟，绝对是的。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023 年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中惊人的矛盾之处。由此开始了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？
or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，新闻报道劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏。你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。
podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games. You get stupid games. prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜》 Trust me, babe 播客。此时此刻最难以接受的事情是，你无法改变已经发生的事情的结果，
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The hardest thing to kind of come to terms with at this point is that you cannot change the outcome of what has happened
不管你多么希望能够改变。你知道，你内心的担忧和压力，它在呼唤你采取行动。它自然地促使、呼唤你去做点什么，去奔跑，去解决问题。然而你知道，导致你压力的那件事，你是无法解决的。你知道，你无法修复一场选举。你无法修复你现在所经历的任何政治状态，
as much as you might want to. You know, the worry and the stress within you, it is calling you to act. It is naturally causing, calling you, to do something, to run, to fix the problem. Whilst you kind of know that the thing that is causing your stress, you can't fix that. You know, you can't fix an election. You can't fix whatever the political state is that you're experiencing right now
就像你可以修复与朋友的冲突或修复工作中的失误那样。这类情况，这些政治的、全球的情况，在它们对心理产生的影响方面是非常独特且罕见的，因为我们的工具箱里通常没有技能来处理如此巨大、可怕且我们实际上无能为力的事情。我们太习惯于那些可能会面对但自然有办法解决的更日常的问题了。所以我们在这种情况下需要做的是从根本上改变我们的心态。如果我们无法改变环境，我们就可以改变我们对环境的看法。我们需要采取一种非常反直觉的视角，
the way that you could fix a conflict with a friend or you could fix a screw up at work. These kinds of situations, these political, global situations, they're very unique and they're very rare in the impact that they have on a cycle. psychologically because we don't typically have the skills in our toolkit to deal with something so big and scary that we can't actually do anything about. We're so used to more everyday problems that might confront us, but which we naturally have a way through. So what we need in this situation is to essentially change our mindset. If we can't change our circumstances, we can change how we think about it. And we need to adopt a very counterintuitive perspective
那就是斯多葛学派的视角。我们几乎需要——虽然这感觉很不自然——但在所有糟糕的事情中放松并接受它。我知道这听起来很令人困惑。我知道这听起来像是，是的，就是随它去吧。但让我解释一下这意味着什么。斯多葛学派是古希腊哲学，基本上意味着挺过你无法与之抗衡的风暴，任由巨浪从你身上拍打而过。它关乎于哪怕在完全、彻底不舒服的时候也要忍受苦难，因为
which is that of a stoic. We need to almost, and it feels unnatural, but relax into all that's terrible. I know that sounds confusing. I know that sounds like, yeah, just like be okay with it. But let me explain what that means. So stoicism is an ancient Greek philosophy that basically means weathering the storm that you cannot fight and just letting the waves roll over you. It's about basically enduring hardship even when it is completely utterly uncomfortable because the
如果与你无法控制的事情进行抗争和挣扎，那替代方案就是受折磨。这基本上是在说，当环境无法改变时，你可以控制的是你选择承受多少痛苦。某种程度的痛苦并不是，你知道的，可选择的，但这有点像当你在海里被巨浪击打时。而你只是在拼命挣扎着游泳，拼命把头探出水面，而人们有时会说你只需要浮起来，对吧？这就是我们接下来要谈论的。这一部分非常重要。你想要考虑什么是你无法控制的，因为斯多葛学派并不意味着将
alternative of fighting and struggling against what you can't control, that alternative is suffering. It's basically saying that when circumstances cannot be changed, the thing that you can control is the level to which you choose to suffer. Some level of suffering is not, you know, optional, but it's almost like when you are being beat down by waves, like in the ocean. and you're just like struggling to swim and you're struggling to get your head underwater and they say sometimes you just need to float right that's what we're going to talk about now this component is very important you want to think about what you can't control because soicism it does not mean putting
你的头埋进沙子里，并不意味着放弃所有激进主义，停止你正在做的事情。它真正教导我们的是，我们应该只考虑我们能够控制的事情：我们自己的想法、我们自己的行动、我们自己的反应，而其他的一切，比如他人的意见、外部事件（例如选举），归根结底都是我们无法控制的。你知道，我们投下选票，我们教育家人和朋友，也许我们参加竞选，但当尘埃落定后，我们无法控制别人如何看待这个世界。这太令人沮丧了。就像，我懂那种和某人说话，只想抓住他们说“难道你没看到眼前发生的事吗，难道你看不到这个吗？这不好。动动你的脑子。难道你看不到这一点吗，像我
your head in the sand it does not mean to abandon all activism to stop whatever you're doing what it really teaches us is that we should only be thinking about what we can control so our own thoughts our own actions, our own responses, everything else, like others' opinions, external events, like an election. That is ultimately beyond our control. You know, we cast our vote, we educate our family and friends, maybe we campaign, but when the day is done, we can't control how anyone else sees the world. And that is so frustrating. Like, I know the feeling of talking to someone and just wanting to grab them and say, like, can't you see what is happening in front of you. Can't you see this? Like, this is not good. Use your brain. Like, can't you see this the way that I
这样看？”这不是我们随时都有权力去掌控的。所以斯多葛学派也鼓励接受事情就是一团糟这一现实。事情现在就是一团糟。但尽管如此，你还是选择闭上眼睛，深呼吸，寻找你的内心的花园。找到你内心那个无人能触及、无可企及的地方，在这个空间里安坐，任由外界一切喧嚣狂乱。你拥有、我们所有人都拥有一个内在的庇护所，我们可以去滋养它，这有助于我们在最艰难的时刻坚持下来并保持韧性。我喜欢把我的内心的斯多葛想象成这个巨型版本的自己，正被某个人大喊大叫。某个人在对我大喊大叫，他们充满了仇恨，
can see this? And that's not something that we have the power over all the time. So stoicism also encourages accepting when things are just shit. Things are just shit right now. But you choose, despite it all, to close your eyes, breathe in deep and find your inner garden. Find that place within you that no one can touch, that nothing can reach. and sit within that space as everything kind of rages on outside. You have, all of us have, an inner sanctuary that we can kind of water that helps us endure and be resilient, even in the hardest of times. I like to picture, you know, my inner stoic as this giant version of myself, who is being yelled at by someone. Some person is yelling and screaming at me and they are full of hate,
但他们不知道的是，我周围有一个像盾牌一样的东西，让一切都变得非常沉闷和缓慢，当我看着他们出汗、尖叫、唾沫横飞、生气时，我却没有受到丝毫影响。我只是在观察，哪怕这让他们变得越来越沮丧，我内心的这个斯多葛版本，这个形象就是我试图带入到这些非常不舒服、不幸、糟糕的情况中的形象。就像我是一尊受到原力场保护的雕像，当我把那些我无法控制的事情（比如这个非常愤怒的局面、这个愤怒的人）屏蔽在外时，
but what they don't know is that there is this like shield around me that makes everything really muffled and slow and as I'm watching them like sweat and scream and spit and get angry, I am untouched by it. I am just observing, even as that, you know, makes them more and more frustrated, this stoic version of me, this image is what I try and bring to these really uncomfortable, unfortunate, terrible situations. Like I'm a statue protected by. a force field and as I tune out what I can't control, this like very angry situation, this angry
我被允许去调频，并且能够调频到我能控制的事情上。那么，你能控制哪些事情呢？你能控制你对他人生活的影响。你能控制你向人们展现的爱。你能控制你回馈给社区的东西。你能控制你的激进主义、你的创造、你的投票、你当前的环境、你选择消费什么、你选择相信什么。对我来说最重要的一点是，我可以选择将善良带入每一个情境中。这是我人生哲学中非常、非常重要的一部分。正是这种理念支撑着我走过了澳大利亚的政治不确定性。而且，你知道，我们最近经历了一场，我想就像是一场绝对
person, I am allowed to tune in and I am able to tune into what I can. So what are the things you can control? You can control your impact on people's lives. You can control the love that you show people. You can control what you give back to your community. You can control your activism, what you create, your vote, your current environment, what you choose to consume, what you choose to believe. And the biggest one for me is I can choose the kindness that I choose to bring to every situation. And this is a really, really important part of my life philosophy. One of the things that has brought me through political uncertainty in Australia. And, you know, we had a recent, I guess, like, referendum that was just absolutely.
糟糕的全民公投。当时安慰我的是，当世界看起来非常、非常丑陋和可怕时，我依然选择让人类相信善良，让人类相信爱。我遇到的每一个人，我都要确保他们离开时感受到爱。我将确保他们在结束这次互动时知道我尊重他们、我关心他们。就像，我会成为善良的化身。我会把我想看到的更多东西回馈给世界。当我们面对政治不确定性和政治焦虑时，拥有这样一种非常深厚的个人哲学，你知道，这可以带来更少的压力、更好的心理健康，
terrible. And what comforted me then, when the world just seemed very, very ugly and hideous, was that I continued to choose to make people believe in humanity and make them believe in kindness. Every person that I come across, I'm going to make sure they leave and that they know love. And I will make sure that they exit that interaction and they know that I respect them and I care about them. Like, I will be kindness. I will put back into the world what I want to see more of. When we have this really deep personal philosophy in the face of political uncertainty and political anxiety, you know, that can lead to less stress, better mental well-being,
以及更强的自主感或能力感，几乎就像你拥有一个只有你能控制的深井，你可以在任何情况下从中汲取力量。有一项了不起的元分析，也就是，基本上是对关于这件事的研究的研究，关于拥有使命感意味着什么的研究。它是由美国精神病学协会在 2003 年进行的。他们基本上所说和发现的是，当你拥有一个深厚的信仰体系、你信任且在乎的东西，并且你可以看着它说，“这就是我来这里的理由，这就是我要带给各种情况的东西”。
and a greater sense of agency or capability, almost like you have this very deep well that only you control and that you can pull from in every single circumstance. And there was an amazing meta-analysis, which is, basically a study of studies about this very thing, about what it means to have a sense of purpose. And it was done in 2003 by the American Psychiatric Association. And what they basically said and what they found was that when you have a deep belief system and something that you trust and that you care about and that you can look at and say, that is why I'm here, this is what I'm going to bring to situations.
它会建立更强的韧性，尤其是当你经历负面或不确定的情况时，比如我们在这些时代所看到的那些。那些拥有可以依靠的深厚信仰体系的人，要坚韧得多，也更有能力挺过无论发生什么状况。我真的、真的鼓励大家找到属于你自己的版本。如果你愿意，你可以偷走我的。去吧。请便。去吧。偷走我的吧。但最重要的是，你得拥有某种东西，某种感觉像是你自己的东西，并且你可以把它带入你自己的宇宙中。而你的宇宙就是，你知道的，你周遭的半径，它会继续触及你生活中的每个人，进入各个房间，并产生影响。
It builds greater resilience, especially when you were experiencing. to negative or on certain situations like those that we're seeing in these times. People who had this deep belief system that they could rest upon, they were so much more resilient and able to push through whatever was going on. And I really, really encourage you to find your version of this. You can steal mine if you want. Go for it. Please. Go for it. Steal mine. But what is so important is that you have something and you have something that feels like your own and that you can bring to your own universe and your own universe is, you know, the radius around you, which goes on to touch everyone in your life, that goes on to enter rooms, that goes on to make an impact.
拥抱斯多葛原则的另一个部分，是真正专注于活在当下。现在，我想不久前我做过一整集关于这个主题的节目，但我记不清具体是第几期了。非常值得一听，尤其是现在这个时候，但知道你能控制什么的一部分，绝对意味着专注于此时此刻真正发生在你面前的事情。这确实需要重新与你的感官建立联系。停下来一秒钟。你能看到什么？我希望你现在找出五样是绿色的东西。你能听到的距离你最远的声音是什么？真正停下来。那个远处的听觉是什么？你身体的哪些部位正在接触
Another part of embracing stoic principles is really focusing on being present. Now, I did do a whole episode on this, I think a little while back, and I cannot remember the number from the top of my head. Worth listening to, especially right now, but part of knowing what you can control definitely means focusing on what is actually going on in front of you right now. And that really involves reconnecting with your senses. Just pause for a second. What can you see? I want you to look for like five things right now that are the colour green. What is the furthest sound from you that you can hear? Really pause. What is that faraway sound? What parts of your body are touching you? your chair, are touching your steering wheel, or touching the ground, really like zone in on where
你的椅子，正接触你的方向盘，或者正接触地面，真正像这样锁定你的皮肤与表面相连的地方。在此时此刻你周围的直接环境中，有没有任何危险存在于这一刻？你知道的，在你的，在你的房间里，在你的车里，在健身房里，无论你在哪里，你真的处于身体危险之中吗？有什么东西会在此刻伤害你吗？答案很可能是否定的。但我们确实感受到的政治焦虑让我们觉得，在任何时候都可能出现某种威胁，并对你造成严重的伤害。我们必须尽量减少这种感觉。是的，在未来，你可能会经历非常严峻的挑战。会有一些你无法控制的事情可能会伤害你。但现在，你不能一直处于那种预料这些事情的状态中。你施加给身体和心灵的压力，以及那种
your skin is connecting to a surface. And in your immediate surroundings right now, is there any danger present in this moment? You know, in your, in your room, in your car, at the gym, wherever you are, are you actually in physical danger? Is there something that is going to hurt you right now? And the answer is probably not. But the political anxiety we do feel does make us feel like at any point there is a threat that could come out and do you some serious harm. And we have to try and minimize that feeling. Yes, in the future, you may experience really hard challenges. There will be things that you cannot control that may hurt you. But right now, you cannot be in that state of anticipating those things constantly. The pressure that you put on your body and your mind and like the level of
充斥在你系统中的皮质醇水平，那种由于这种持续的高度警惕而导致你的免疫系统彻底受损的状态，这确实是我们真正需要尽量减少的事情，因为这样当可怕的事情真的发生时，如果它真的发生，当某个巨大的改变真的出现时，这意味着你实际上没有资源去应对它，因为你花了太多的时间去担心它。所以现在，我只希望你记住，在你周围的空间里，你并不处于危险之中。而在那些你确实觉得你所有的情绪都在上升、都在像火山爆发一样的时刻，真正依靠那些非常古老的、经受过时间考验的、我们的身体可以通过与大自然重新连接来平静下来的方法。大自然在这样的时刻是如此卓越，我希望你走到外面去，就像现在这样，或者在你听完这集节目后，脱掉鞋子，脱掉袜子，把它们坚定地扎根在泥土里、草地里、小溪边，你知道“去接触一下大自然”这句话吗？是的，去接触一下大自然吧，事实证明，这可能确实是我们应该多做的事情。这里面其实有一些真相和真正的好处。2019 年有一篇来自哈佛健康（Harvard Health）的文章，它表明仅仅每天在户外呆 20 到 30 分钟，
cortisol that you will have flooding through your systems, the way that your immune system is just going to be completely compromised by this constant hypervigilance, that is something that we really do need to minimize because then when something terrible does happen, if it happens when some big change does occur, what that's going to mean is that you don't actually have the resources to deal with it because you spend a lot of. lot of time worrying about it. So right now, I just want you to remember that in the space around you, you are not in danger. And in those moments when you do just feel like all of your emotions, they're rising to the surface, they're like exploding, really rely on the very ancestral
将其作为你日常生活的一部分，或者甚至只是在自然空间中度过，比如在室外吃午饭，真的有助于降低荷尔蒙压力水平。因为，你知道的，大自然、户外，当你仔细想想，那就是我们归属的环境。那是我们的身体自然学会平静下来的地方，
old ways, the tried and tested ways that our body can calm itself by reconnecting with nature. nature is just so remarkable in moments like this i want you to go outside like right now or after you finish this episode take your shoes off take your socks off plant them like firmly in the dirt in the grass in the creek and you know the saying like go and touch some grass like yeah go and touch some grass turns out you know that's actually probably something we should be doing more of there's actually some truth and some serious good to that there was an article for from 2019 from Harvard Health, and it showed that just doing 20 to 30 minutes in nature a day,
那是它感觉最真实、联系最紧密的地方。所以在那些一切都感觉如此喧闹、愤怒且压力巨大的时刻，我需要你去接触这个非常重要、你知道的、内心中深处能够感受到与大自然连接并知道自己在那个时刻是安全的深层部分。这对于气候焦虑也非常、非常有用。如果你目前正具体地与此做斗争，这很容易发生，作为一个对气候感到非常焦虑、并且有很多对气候感到非常焦虑的朋友的人。你知道，这很容易让人陷入灾难性的情景，尤其是当你
making that part of your routine, or even just spending it in natural spaces, like eating your lunch outside, it really helped lower hormonal stress levels. Because, you know, nature, the outdoors, when you think about it, like, that is the environment in which we belong. That is where our body has naturally learnt to calm itself down.
一整天都待在室内，被锁在办公室里时，就像，“大自然还存在吗，因为我看不见它，而我在这些糟糕透顶的新闻文章里读到的所有东西，都让一切感觉糟糕得多。”所以，当你确实给自己机会走到外面，看到我们的自然世界中有很多东西依然活着。有美丽的、依然在蓬勃发展的空间。这会把你拉回现实一秒钟。我还有一个朋友喜欢做自然手账。
that is where it feels most real and most connected. So in those moments where like everything just feels so loud and angry and just so stressful, I need you to go and access this very important, you know, deep part of you that can feel connected to nature and know that it is safe in that moment. This is also very, very good for climate anxiety. If that is something that you're struggling with specifically right now, it can be very easy and someone who is very anxious about the climate and has many friends who are very anxious about the climate. You know, it's very easy to disaster scenario, especially when you're
所以她有一个手账笔记本和一堆色彩缤纷的笔，她会走到大自然中，寻找一朵花、一片叶子、一个河床、一块石头、任何美丽的东西。然后她基本上会把她身处的那个情境记录在手账里，或者她会画一幅这片叶子的画。这实际上真的非常、非常美，她强烈推荐这样做。所以，找到你的斯多葛人格，找到你的个人哲学，并尽可能地活在当下，这是我的前三个建议。我们要稍作休息。
like inside all day and when you're locked up in the office, it's like, oh, does nature still exist anymore because I don't see it and all I'm reading in these terrible, terrible news articles, like it just makes everything feel so much worse. So when you do give yourself the opportunity to go outside and see that there is a lot about our natural world. that is still alive. There are beautiful spaces that are still thriving. Just brings you back for a second. I also have a friend who does like nature journaling.
但当我们回来时，我们将讨论应对当前政治焦虑的最后三种方法。所以我们一会儿就回来。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身的科学，
So she has a journal like notebook and a bunch of like colorful pens and she will go out into nature and find a flower, a leaf, a riverbed, a rock, anything beautiful. And she will basically journal about that situation that she's in or she'll do it, like, draw a picture of this leaf. and it's actually really, really beautiful, and she highly recommends it. So finding your stoic persona, finding your personal philosophy, and being as present as possible, those are my first three tips. We are going to take a short break.
以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油
But when we return, we're going to discuss my final three ways that we can deal with our political anxiety at this time. So we will be right back in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when they're is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO.%，可在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈 80 年代瘾品的节目。澄清一下，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时都可以聊瘾品，但只是想让大家知道。
were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期讨论瘾品的节目了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在台面上了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这就是
What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
乔治·布什跟小金（Little Kim）到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集里，我们都会聚焦于此，剖析当年的发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不只是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因，但只是想让大家知道这一点。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。我开始发现这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病这个话题摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，但我们仍然在追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
你觉得在人间做一个好人重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。和我（基尔·盖恩斯）一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio App。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·莱斯比安（Greg Lesbian）、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个惯犯骗子。我感觉像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Following really big political events or like significant turning points when something major happens, our tendency is just to get as much information as possible to find any news site or any story that may tell us something that we don't know. Such a human instinct to know more is to be more aware and is to be more capable and more able to survive.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》之“相信我，宝贝”。在发生重大的政治事件或重要的转折点之后，每当有重大事情发生时，我们的倾向往往是尽可能多地获取信息，寻找任何新闻网站或任何可能告诉我们一些我们不知道的事情的故事。这种了解更多的本能是人类的天性，为了解更多就是为了更有意识，就是更有能力并且更有能力生存。
That is really where our hunger for knowledge, especially in these situations, comes from. And we feel very bitterly and strangely soothed by knowing more, even when the thing we know more about actually makes us want to like scream and throw up. That is how I felt the entire day, the other day was just like, wow, I can't get away from my phone, even though it's making me physically sick. That is the paradox of doom scrolling, spending so much time online and looking for more information and more sides to like an unfolding story that we actually end up hurting our mental health more than helping it. It is so easy to fall into this trap and it's one that I certainly have over the years glued to my phone even when I know that I'm just going to feel worse and the trick is
这确实是我们对知识的渴望的来源，尤其是在这些情况下。而且，当我们知道得更多时，我们会感到一种非常痛苦却又奇怪的安慰，即使我们所知道的事情实际上让我们想要尖叫和呕吐。前几天我一整天都是这种感觉，就觉得，哇，我无法离开我的手机，尽管它让我身体感到恶作剧。这就是末日刷屏（doom scrolling）的悖论，花那么多时间在网上寻找更多信息和不断发展的故事的更多面，以至于我们最终伤害了我们的心理健康，而不是帮助它。陷入这个陷阱是如此容易，这绝对是我多年来犯过的错误，即使我知道这只会让自己感觉更糟糕，我也依然死死盯着手机，而诀窍在于
to be informed but not overwhelmed. That is your that is your equation informed but not overwhelmed and we do that by limiting how much you are allowed to keep investigating. I want you to have environments or points in your day when you are kind of allowed to be dead to what is happening in the world, whether that means unfollowing like news accounts on social media so that you can only read the news on your laptop at work so that, you know, outside of business hours, like you can't read the news. You know, you're still informed.
保持知情，而不是不知所措。这就是你的公式：保持知情，而不是不知所措，我们通过限制你被允许继续调查的程度来做到这一点。我希望你在一天中有这样的环境或时刻，你可以对世界上正在发生的事情“装死”，无论是取消关注社交媒体上的新闻账号，这样你就只能在工作时的笔记本电脑上阅读新闻，以便你知道，在工作时间之外，你无法阅读新闻。你知道，你仍然了解情况。
You still know what's going on, but do you really need to know right now in this instance, as soon as you wake up? You know, I found that to be so terrible for me. I would wake up, pick up my phone and it's like, here is a disaster. Here is like a bombing. Here is like, you know, children dead. Here is whatever. Like, here is Trump winning.
你仍然知道发生了什么，但你真的需要现在、在这个瞬间、在你一醒来的时候就知道吗？你知道，我发现这对我的伤害太大了。我醒来，拿起手机，就像是：这里有一场灾难。这里有一场爆炸。这里有，你知道，死去的儿童。这里有随便什么。就像，这里是特朗普获胜。
I know I said I wouldn't talk specifics. I'm very sorry. But, you know, when you wake up and that is the first thing that you see, what you consume is how you feel. It's very much like your media diet. If your media diet is very high in tragic, awful, cruel things, your tiny brain, your human brain, it cannot hold all of that at the same time. You are not meant to hold all of that information at the same time. Truly, like think back to how we have evolved to seek information and from who. It was tribal. It was limited. There was
我知道我说过我不谈具体细节。非常抱歉。但是，你知道，当你醒来时，那是你看到的第一件事，你消费什么，你就会有什么感觉。这很像你的媒体饮食。如果你的媒体饮食中含有大量悲惨、可怕、残忍的事情，你那小小的脑瓜、你的人类大脑，是无法同时承受这一切的。你本不应该同时承受所有这些信息。真的，回想一下我们是如何进化来寻求信息的以及从谁那里寻求。它是部落式的。它是有限的。没有
not enough. You know, you were never going to have enough information at that given point to feel like you knew everything that was going on in the world. Because you, you know, as much as like it's a good thing that we do know so much more about our fellow humans and what they're going through, you have to just remember that your brain has not evolved to have as much access to information. So it is natural if you just feel completely confronted by that. And especially, when our new seeking gets very excessive. You will become burnt out. You will become fatigued.
足够的。你知道，在给定的时间点，你永远不会有足够的信息让你觉得你知道世界上正在发生的一切。因为你，你知道，尽管我们对同胞以及他们正在经历的事情了解得更多是一件好事，但你必须记住，你的大脑并没有进化到能够接触到如此多的信息。所以，如果你觉得完全被这些信息所冲击，那是很自然的。尤其是当我们的求知欲变得过头时。你会精疲力竭。你会感到疲惫。
So for the sake of yourself and for the sake of having energy and effort to put towards really important things, to put towards those you love, to put towards your community, to put towards yourself, you do need to find a healthy relationship with not just what news you access, but when you access it. So again, informed but not overwhelmed. Also, just sprinkle some good news in there. You know, there was a landmark study from just a few years ago from a university in Alabama, and it found that people who share and access positive news stories mixed in with their normal news.
因此，为了你自己的利益，为了拥有精力和努力去投入真正重要的事情，去投入你所爱的人身上，去投入你的社区，去投入你自己，你确实需要与你获取什么新闻以及何时获取新闻建立一种健康的联系。所以再次强调，保持知情，而不是不知所措。此外，在其中加入一些好消息。你知道，几年前阿拉巴马大学有一项具有里程碑意义的研究，研究发现，那些在日常新闻中穿插分享和接触积极新闻故事的人，
After two weeks, they reported being happier and more emotionally stable. They felt more optimistic about the future than those who didn't. And it didn't mean that they didn't care. I think sometimes we're like, oh, if I feel optimistic, well, then, I'm not going to be motivated to change anything. I'm not going to be motivated to having conversations. I'm just not going to care anymore. Actually, no, we need optimism. We need to believe that things can get better. We need to believe that the world can be brighter. We need optimism more than we need pessimism in times like this. So just remember if you're feeling like shit, your media diet might be a
两周后，他们报告说自己更快乐、情绪更稳定。与那些没有这样做的人相比，他们对未来感到更加乐观。这并不意味着他们不关心。我想有时我们会想，哦，如果我感到乐观，那么我就没有动力去改变任何事情。我将没有动力去进行对话。我只是不再在乎了。其实不然，我们需要乐观。我们需要相信事情会变好。我们需要相信世界会更光明。在这样的时刻，我们需要乐观多于悲观。所以请记住，如果你感觉糟透了，你的媒体饮食可能是一个
factor because you are what you consume. So if you need a rest day from chaos and tragedy, no one's going to blame you. No one's going to say that you're being naive or ignorant. You're having a rest day. It's okay. And you know, on a similar point, just as we are what we consume, we are also who we surround ourselves with. The power of community in times when we are experiencing political anxiety cannot be overstated. Community is the most psychologically important thing in times like this. And I know that is a big statement to make, but I just think that it heals so much. It is so protective when it comes to our mental health during periods of political uncertainty and crisis. And it's so hard going through anything alone, let alone what
因素，因为你吃什么就像什么。所以如果你需要从混乱和悲剧中休息一天，没有人会怪你。没有人会说你幼稚或无知。你只是在过一个休息日，这没关系。你知道，同样的道理，正如我们吃什么就像什么一样，我们身边的人也是如此。在我们经历政治焦虑的时期，社区的力量怎么强调都不为过。在这样的时期，社区是心理上最重要的事情。我知道这是一个很大的陈述，但我只是认为它治愈了太多。在政治不确定性和危机时期，它对我们的心理健康具有极强的保护作用。独自经历任何事情都非常艰难，更不用说那种
feels like the world ending, let alone what feels like a complete shift from what you expected. So this is really the time to engage and connect even when you want to withdraw. And I will say that is a problem that I have. When I am emotionally confronted by something, when I'm quite stressed, I just feel like I have absolutely nothing in the tank to give to my relationship. So I self-isolate. I will pull away. I'll hide away in my house.
感觉世界末日般的体验了，更不用说那种感觉与你的预期完全脱节的体验了。所以这真的是参与和建立联系的时候，即使你想要退缩。我得说，这也是我存在的问题。当我受到某种情绪上的冲击，当我感到相当压力时，我就会觉得我的油箱里绝对没有一滴油可以用来维系我的关系。所以我自我隔离。我会退缩。我会躲在我的房子里。
I don't want to see anyone. I don't want to talk to anyone. I don't want to make plans. I'm not replying to messages. It's a terrible habit of mine, one that I'm trying to break. and the way that I'm trying to break it is just consciously being like remembering, consciously remembering that when I am around people, I do feel better. Remembering that cause and effect that always typically happens.
我不想见任何人。我不想跟任何人说话。我不想做任何计划。我不回复消息。这是我的一个坏习惯，一个我正试图改掉的坏习惯。而我试图改掉它的方法，就是有意识地提醒自己，有意识地提醒自己，当我跟人们在一起时，我确实感觉更好。记住那种通常总会发生的因果关系。
I don't feel better when I self-isolate. I do feel better when I'm around other people, especially people that I trust, that I love, that care for me and I care for them. That is community, that is belonging. I will say at the moment there is a tendency and I found that, in my friendships to just like catch up and everyone just has like, it's just like what the fuck is happening and just like wants to talk about so much stuff and just wants to, you know, just wants to just get it off their chest. That's healthy. There is a healthy level of
自我隔离并不能让我感觉更好。当我跟其他人在一起时，我确实感觉更好，尤其是跟我信任的、我爱的、关心我我也关心他们的人在一起。那是社区，那是归属感。我得说，目前有一种趋势，我在我的友谊中也发现了这一点，就是聚在一起，每个人都像是：这到底是怎么回事？就只想谈论很多事情，就只想，你知道，只想一吐为快。这很健康。存在着一个健康的水平，即
complaining and seeking comfort, especially just feeling shitty together. That's sometimes just one of the most healing things in the world. It's just to be like, great, can we both agree that we're not in a good mood? Can we both agree that we're not feeling great? Beautiful. Now I just feel a little bit less alone. But I do just want you to be conscious of when it gets to a level where you just feel entirely hopeless. That kind of like collective anxiety that we tend to feel when we are in a big group or talking to our friends and everyone's just getting more and more angry and frustrated and scared. That is a symptom of when group psychology kind of lets us down. You know, it's not group think. It's basically just that when we are around people that we are close to, we do tend
抱怨和寻求安慰，尤其是大家一起感觉很糟糕。有时候这绝对是世界上最具治愈的事情之一。那就是说：太好了，我们能不能都同意我们现在心情不好？我们能不能都同意我们感觉不太好？太美妙了。现在我感觉不那么孤单了。但我确实希望你们能意识到，当这种情况达到一种让你感到彻底绝望的程度时。那种集体焦虑，当我们身处大群体中或与朋友交谈时，每个人都变得越来越愤怒、沮丧和害怕，往往就会产生这种焦虑。这就是群体心理让我们失望时的症状。你知道，这不是群体思维。基本上只是当我们和亲近的人在一起时，我们确实倾向于
to absorb their emotions and that tends to heighten our own reactions to things. So please be conscious of it, be aware of it. I think that having a rant, having a debrief, just getting it off your chest, it's like a plateau. Like it gets healthy to a point. No, it's almost like a, wow, I can't remember my math, but it's almost like an upside down you and someone's going to tell me what that is. I just can't remember it right now. But it gets, it feels healthy to a point. And then we flip. over and we go down the other side. There is a limit. So be aware of when it's doing more harm than good. I really learnt this from my mum and I learnt this with my mum. Sometimes she is so passionate about these things. She is such a huge, you know, political and social activist and she cares so deeply
吸收他们的情绪，这往往会加剧我们对事情的反应。所以请对此保持清醒，意识到这一点。我认为发泄一下，做一个复盘，把胸中的郁闷吐出来，就像是一个平台期。它在一定程度上是健康的。不，这几乎就像是一个……天哪，我不记得我的数学了，但它几乎就像是一个倒U形，总会有人告诉我那是什么。我只是现在记不起来了。但这在一定程度上感觉很健康。然后我们翻转过来，走向另一边。这是有限度的。所以要注意它什么时候带来的危害大于好处。我真的是从我妈妈那里学到这一点的，我也从我妈妈身上学到了这一点。有时她对这些事情充满热情。她是一个如此伟大的、你知道的，政治和社会活动家，她如此深切地
about every single human on this earth that sometimes, and I know this is going to sound insane, but it's too much. It's like, okay, I cannot talk about this. I did not. for the fifth night in a row, I cannot get, because I'm going to get angry. I'm going to get really frustrated. I'm going to just feel like so sad and so like, it's, you know, I just can't do that. You know, there has to be a break for me. So I often just say to her, like, we're going to do five minutes where you can talk to me about, we can talk to each other about, you know, what kind of terrible news story is going on.
关心着地球上的每一个人类，以至于有时——我知道这听起来很疯狂——但这太多了。就像是：好吧，我不能再谈这个了。我不能连续第五个晚上，因为我要生气了。我要变得非常沮丧。我要觉得自己太悲伤、太……你知道，我就是做不到。你知道，我必须休息一下。所以我经常对她说：我们花五分钟时间，你可以跟我谈谈，我们可以互相谈谈，你知道，到底发生了什么可怕的新闻故事。
We can talk about politics or we can just talk about whatever we want to do with this thing. And then we have to have a break. because I don't want my relationship with you to be defined by feeling a heightened level of stress every time that I walk away because I feel like all the world's problems are resting on our shoulders. So step away from conversations when you're at your limit and truly ask yourself, I know it feels like a selfish question, but do ask yourself, like, is this going to change anything? Is this going to change anything? Listening to this for like the fifth time today, getting upset about it, is it just going to make me feel worse and is it just going to mean that when it does come to
我们可以谈论政治，或者我们可以只谈论任何我们想用这件事情做的事。然后我们必须休息一下。因为我不想我和你的关系被这种感觉所定义：每次我离开时都带着高度的压力，因为我觉得全世界的问题都压在我们肩上。所以当你到了极限时，离开对话，真正地问自己一个问题——我知道这感觉像是一个自私的问题，但请问问自己：这会改变任何事情吗？这会改变任何事情吗？今天第五次听这个，为此感到沮丧，这只会让我感觉更糟糕吗？这是否意味着当真正需要做点什么的时候，我将没有精力去做了？这正是我想要总结的。你需要用你的焦虑做点什么，而最好的方法就是开始回馈。这是一个完美的时机，可以真正反思你能为那些需要帮助的人做些什么。
doing something, I'm not going to have the energy for that. This is really what I want to finish on. You need to do something with your anxiety and the best way to do that is to start giving back. This is a perfect time to really reflect on what you can be doing for those that need it. our anxiety and distress, it does feel worse when we sit in it and when we let it get bigger and bigger and bigger by thinking that we can outthink all of the world's problems, that we can out think how shit the situation is when we can find a way out. We're going to return to those principles of stoicism. Concern yourself with what you can do and what you can control, and we can control what we give back. I really start to think about
我们的焦虑和痛苦，当我们沉浸其中，当我们通过认为自己可以想出解决世界上所有问题的方法、当我们在寻找出路时认为自己可以想出如何摆脱这糟糕的处境，而让它变得越来越大、越来越大时，它确实会感觉更糟糕。我们将回归斯多葛学派的原则。关注你能做的事和你能控制的事，而我们可以控制我们所回馈的事。我真正开始思考的是
A cause that you could get involved in that makes you feel like you can make a difference in your local community. I think we really don't acknowledge how much actually gets done on the backs of people who volunteer their time and who care deeply and give their energy and give their passion and give their money to a cause that they care about. And oh my goodness, do they not make the biggest difference in some people's lives? I want you to find that thing, that thing that really drives you. and often here's a little tip about how you can figure that out. The thing that is most upset you about the situation, the thing that you feel most upset to see threatened,
一个你可以参与的事业，它能让你觉得你可以在你的本地社区产生影响。我认为我们真的没有承认，有多少事情实际上是在那些奉献时间、深深关心、付出精力、付出热情并向他们关心的事业捐款的人的支持下完成的。哦，天哪，他们在某些人的生活中难道没有产生最大的影响吗？我希望你能找到那件事，那件真正驱使你的事。这里通常有一个小贴士，告诉你如何找出答案。在这种情况下最让你心烦的事，你觉得看到它受到威胁最让你感到沮丧的事，
that is what you care about the most. What makes you the angriest, what makes you the most anxious, what really lights a fire in terms of your sense of justice, that is where you should be devoting your time. I want to take all those feelings and transfer them into a way of giving back. That is just one of the biggest antidotes I have found to any form of anxiety, really, but political anxiety in particular, is really, and I just want to hammer this home. You cannot control.
那才是你最关心的。是什么让你最愤怒，是什么让你最焦虑，是什么真正点燃了你对正义感的火焰，这才是你应该投入时间的地方。我想把所有这些情绪都转化并投入到回馈的方式中。这是我发现的对抗任何形式焦虑（尤其是政治焦虑）的最伟大解药之一，那就是真正地——我只想反复强调这一点。你无法控制。
There is so much you cannot control. But your little slice of your world, your little universe, you can control that and you can give back and you can make that space happy and you can change people through small daily actions of kindness. and you can seriously change their lives. You can change people's lives by volunteering, by giving back to your community. Feel like it always, you know, as being global citizens and having so much access to the news, it feels like we have to do something big constantly and we have to be like, you know,
有太多事情是你无法控制的。但你世界的一小片，你的小宇宙，你可以控制它，你可以回馈，你可以让那个空间变得快乐，你可以通过每天小小的善举改变人们。你可以真正地改变他们的生活。你可以通过志愿服务、通过回馈你的社区来改变人们的生活。感觉好像总是，你知道，作为一个全球公民，能够接触到如此多的新闻，感觉我们必须不断地做一些大事，我们必须像是，你知道的，
there's so much that's bad about the world. Like, how do I fix it all? You can't. I'm sorry. You can't. But you can, you can focus on something that the people around you need. and be that solution in your local area and in your friendship groups and with your family. I also just want to say a final reminder, it does feel really scary right now.
世界上有那么多不好的事情。我该如何解决这一切？你不能。对不起。你不能。但你可以，你可以专注于你周围的人所需要的东西。成为你当地、你的朋友圈以及你的家庭中的解决方案。我还想做最后的提醒，现在感觉确实真的很可怕。
I know that there are a lot of unknowns and I think a lot of us are thinking, how am I going to be able to cope with this? What's the way forward? Remember that you are capable. You will find a way through. You will survive. You will be okay even when it feels like you won't be. There are people who love you.
我知道有很多未知数，我想我们很多人都在想：我将如何应对这一切？前进的方向是什么？请记住，你是能干的。你会找到出路的。你会活下去的。你会好起来的，即使你觉得不会。有爱你的人，
there are support systems, there are people who are on the same page as you who are not going to abandon you. So just focus on the good as much as you can right now. Political anxiety and political uncertainty is an incredibly natural reaction to changing circumstances that feel threatening and dangerous and it's okay to be feeling that way right now. But you cannot exist in that space forever. There are a lot of things that, I hate to say. It's not that you have to get used to them, but it's kind of like, okay, cool, can't change that. What can I change? What can I do? Let's focus on that. Let's really, really lean into my friendships, my community, my kindness, my purpose, my beliefs. This is something that's going to be very nourishing for me for this time.
有支持系统，有和你意见一致、不会抛弃你的人。所以现在尽可能多地关注美好事物。政治焦虑和政治不确定性是对感到具有威胁性和危险性的不断变化的环境的极其自然的反应，现在有这种感觉是没问题的。但你不可能永远停留在那个空间里。有很多事情，我讨厌这么说。并不是说你必须习惯它们，而是有点像：好吧，酷，无法改变。我能改变什么？我能做什么？让我们专注于此。让我们真正、真正地依靠我的友谊、我的社区、我的善良、我的目标、我的信仰。这将是在这段时间里对我有很大滋养的事情。
So I am just sending a whole lot of love and a whole lot of comfort. I hope that this episode has just given you a bit of peace today, made you feel a little bit better about the world, made you feel like there is a space where you can come to throughout whatever happens, you know, for comfort and for peace and for safety, you're always welcome here. Your mental health is respected and cared for here and will always be cared for. And I just love that we have such a beautiful little slice of the internet. So thank you so much for listening. I hope you got something from this episode. I hope you enjoyed it. As always, if you did, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Make sure that you are following along
所以我只是送出满满的爱和满满的安慰。我希望这一集今天能给你带来一点平静，让你对世界感觉好一点，让你觉得无论发生什么，都有一个你可以来的地方，为了安慰、为了平静、为了安全，这里永远欢迎你。你的心理健康在这里受到尊重和关怀，并将永远受到关怀。我真的很高兴我们拥有互联网上如此美丽的一小片净土。非常感谢你们的收听。我希望你从这一集中有所收获。我希望你喜欢它。一如既往，如果你喜欢，请随时在 Apple Podcast、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。请确保你一直在关注
for new episodes. I'm going to do an episode specifically on Doom scrolling in a couple of weeks because I feel like that's something that, you know, I just couldn't get into in one, in this episode. There's so much information about it, psychologically, emotionally, like, scientifically, sociologically as well. So stay tuned for that episode. And if you you have anything more you want to say and any suggestions for episodes, you can DM me at that psychology podcast. We would love to hear from you over there. Until next week, stay safe, stay kind. And the most important of all this week, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
新剧集。过几周我会做一集专门关于末日刷屏的节目，因为我觉得这是我在这集里无法深入探讨的内容。关于它的心理、情感、科学以及社会学方面的信息太多了。所以请继续关注那一集。如果你还有更多想说的话以及对节目的任何建议，你可以在私信我（@that psychology podcast）。我们很想在那里听到你的声音。直到下周，保持安全，保持善良。本周最重要的是，对你自己好一点。我们很快就会交谈。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师
and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations, that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何其他地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你两次篡改了这份特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯比安（Greg Lesbian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧、健康和复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
也就是 TWO%（2%）。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个惯犯骗子时，她们自己采取了行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》之“相信我，宝贝”。在 Look Back at it 播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people Listen to Look Back at it on the I Heart Radio app
我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay），我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
黑人。在 iHeart Radio App 收听 Look Back at it。Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。